je vous pose la question que tout le
monde se pose est-ce que vous avez eu
peur à un moment vraiment comment ne pas
avoir peur
ce bonsoir après 46 heures de cauchemar
à l'école maternelle de Neuilly les
policiers Duret dans libérer ce matin
les six fillettes encore retenues en
otages ainsi que la jeune femme médecin
du corps des sapeurs-pompiers de Paris
qui avait passé la nuit avec elle et
dont nous entendront le témoignage tout
à fait capital le bonheur d'otage a été
abattu de trois balles dans la tête
récit du dénouement avec valergagey
4 petites filles effrayées accrochées au
cou des policiers du Raid il est 7h25
nous assistons sans encore le savoir à
l'épilogue de la prise d'otage ses
enfants viennent juste d'être emportés
de la salle de maternelle où ils étaient
détenus apprenant que le ravisseur a été
tué le petit groupe gagne ensuite
calmement le parc de l'école à peine 30
minutes plus tard Édouard Balladur le
Premier ministre se présente à l'entrée
principale une courte visite suivie de
celle de son ministre de l'Intérieur
pressé par les journalistes Charles
Pasqua et laconique mais heureux
et le forcené est mort
les familles des petits otages sortent
ensuite une à une l'heure n'est pas aux
grandes déclarations mais à l'émotion
il était très content très contente
à 8h on ignore encore les conditions
réelles du dénouement Nicolas Sarkozy le
maire de Neuilly qui a participé au
négociations apportera un premier
témoignage sur le ravisseur
ça fait maintenant près de 18 heures
qu'on arrivait plus à sortir un enfant
et c'était plus facile au départ parce
que comme toutes les deux heures on
arrivait en sortir et puis tout d'un
coup c'est bloqué il s'est dit que ses
enfants c'était sa protection voulaient
plus en sortir il y avait plus rien à
faire ça il ne voulait plus rien
entendre on a tout essayé j'ai été
chercher l'argent il était très méfiant
il faisait tout raconté il a voulu
absolument que je lui donne les
montants des devises en Deutschmark et
en dollars enfin bref il y a des
discussions qui ont été irréelles puis
on aperçu enfin ces deux femmes
exemplaires Évelyne Lambert médecin
capitaine des pompiers de Paris et
Laurence Dreyfus la jeune institutrice
côte à côte comme sur cette image
pendant 47 heures elles ont protégé les
enfants en fin de matinée l'école avait
presque retrouvé une allure normale la
rentrée des classes c'est pour mardi une
rentrée sourire aux lèvres
les tireurs d'élite ont profité d'un
moment d'assouplissement du ravisseur
pour pénétrer dans la classe récit de ce
que les spécialistes appellent une
opération de neutralisation avec
Christophe Tortora
dès 5h30 ce matin les hommes du RAID ont
reçu l'ordre d'intervenir Charles Pasqua
a donné son accord reste à trouver le
moment propice attendre que le preneur
d'otage fatigué relâche son attention
des moyens visuels et sonores introduits
dans la classe leur fournissent cette
certitude il est 7h25 en un éclair deux
policiers du Raid pénètrent dans la
classe s'approche à moins de 3 mètres de
l'homme qui se réveille immédiatement il
tire trois balles blindées de 9 mm 3
balles dans la tête de l'autre côté de
la pièce le médecin pédiatre des
pompiers prévenu l’intervention à placer
les six enfants sous les matelas pour
jouer leur dit-elle à la tortue en fait
il s'agit de les protéger au cas où tout
explose au moment où le preneur d'otage
est abattu une dizaine de policiers du
Raid jaillissent prennent chacun dans
leurs bras un enfant pour le protéger et
l'emmener au loin c'est la raison pour
laquelle on peut les voir sortir de
l'enceinte de l'école un enfant dans
chaque bras toujours la peur de
l'explosion l'opération en tout dans la
salle de classe n'aura plus de 5
secondes
le preneur d'otage Eric Schmitt un homme
de 42 ans signé ses messages adressés à
la police des initiales HB comme Human
Bomb se qualificatif de bombe humaine
ait été là s'approprier puisque cet
homme s'était attaché des battants de
dynamite autour de la taille après avoir
mis en place dans la classe un
dispositif de dynamitage
particulièrement sophistiqué reportage
Caroline Laudun Arnaud Leffe
la classe numéro 8 c'est la première
porte à gauche dans le couloir des
maternelles ce matin il irait ni le plus
grand désordre six enfants et trois
adultes venaient de vivre comme dans un
camp retranché deux jours et de nuit
dans une pièce de 40 mètres carrés seul
un petit meuble séparait les enfants de
leur ravisseur il s'était replié au fond
de la classe derrière ces étagères avec
à proximité une radio une télévision et
un thermos de café les enfants bloqués
le long de la fenêtre pouvaient dormir
dans le coin bibliothèque tout était
prévu les stores des fenêtres baissées
la lumière Estate et les ouvertures
bouchées
à la demande du preneur d'otage par
l'institutrice évidemment pour éviter
que les forces de police puissent
observer de l'extérieur
ce matin tout dans cette classe marquait
la précipitation avec laquelle les
otages ont quitté la pièce des plus
abandonnées des chaussures oubliées
bientôt ils n'auront pour seul souvenir
que ces quelques dessins réalisés durant
une journée de classe une journée
particulière de 48 heures
au cœur de ce drame de jeunes femmes
dont l'intelligence et le courage ont
certainement éviter le pire et qui
toutes de ont été promus dès ce matin à
titre exceptionnel Chevalier dans
l'Ordre de la Légion d'Honneur tout
d'abord l'institutrice Laurence Dreyfus
dont c'était il faut le rappeler le
premier poste et qui avait tenu à rester
avec les enfants pour les rassurer
Laurence Dreyfus que vous voyez sortir
de chez elle ce matin accompagné de
policiers et qui est parti semble-t-il
se reposer dans sa famille la France
entière a commencé par son ministre
François Bayrou a salué ce matin son
héroïsme
après Laurence déjà baptisée dans la
presse l'institutrice courage Evelyne
capitaine courage une jeune médecin de
26 ans la seule au grade de capitaine
dans le corps des sapeurs-pompiers de
Paris que j'ai eu l'honneur de recevoir
en compagnie de Michel find dans notre
journal de 13h et ville Lambert qui
était ce matin seul en compagnie des
enfants lorsque l'assaut a été lancé
je vous pose la question que tout le
monde se pose est-ce que vous avez eu
peur à un moment vraiment comment ne pas
savoir peur je pense qu'on a peur tout
le temps et plus précisément quand on
sent que ça se précise
mais je pense qu'il y a également la
volonté de faire quelque chose l'envie
que cette attente s'arrête donc
n'importe quoi pourvu que quelque chose
se passe tout à l'heure que vous aviez
vous aussi bien failli craquer cette
nuit quand vous avez appris que c'était
remis peut-être l'opération a encore
plus tard et la perspective d'une
nouvelle journée d'une nouvelle nuit
d'innaction société le plus terrible
c'était le fait d'attendre sans savoir
que faire hier soir vers 19h j'avais
l'impression que les choses avancaient
bien donc Laurent c'est moi étions avec
les enfants qui étaient relativement
calme comme d'habitude et on pensait
qu'on allait enfin pouvoir faire quelque
chose bouger sortir avec les véhicules
ce qu'il essaie a priori la possibilité
d'une intervention et malheureusement
quand vers 23 heures les négociations
d'avant sont pas le forcené à dire il y
aurait plus rien de fait ce soir ça a
été le moment le plus terrible c'est sûr
le scénario d'intervention est-ce que ça
a été long ça s'est passé comment le
raid a mis au point le scénario j'étais
juste leur indicateur pour savoir
comment était les les affaires à
l'intérieur de la pièce qu'elle était
son état d'esprit à lui qu'elles étaient
ces volontés
donc je leur donnais le renseignement on
va reparler un peu plus en détail mais
au moment du dénouement ce qu'il faut
que les téléspectateurs sachent que
c'est que les enfants étaient réveillés
que vous faisiez son nom de jouer si
j'ai bien compris pour pour en même
temps les regrouper les mettre le plus à
l'abri possible les enfants étaient en
train de s'amuser à faire la tortue pour
se cacher sous les matelas et se cacher
derrière les tables renversées donc il
était une voyait rien il n'était au
courant de jouer pour quelque part le
rassurer même si il était plus ou moins
assoupi il était quelque peu assoupi
mais on jouait de manière à ce que nos
voix constante le rassure et venez ce
qui s'est rendu compte de ce qui se
passait tout dernier moment non vraiment
je ne pense pas puisque les gens du raid
était très proche de lui quand ça s'est
passé et à mon avis ça a été beaucoup
trop bref pour lui il aurait été capable
de mettre feu à ses explosifs
je pense que oui qu'est-ce qui vous fait
dire qu'il était très déterminé
la manière qu'il avait de répéter
systématiquement que de toute façon
vu sa vie
il n'avait plus rien à perdre qu'est-ce
que ça voulait dire du sa vie je n'ai
jamais réussi justement à lui faire
précisé malgré un semblant de climat de
confiance je n'ai jamais pu lui faire
préciser un éventuel problème médical ou
des problèmes autres sociaux qui
pouvaient l'amener à être aussi
désespéré vous avez réussi à le faire
parler sur lui à lui faire expliquer
pourquoi il en était venu là quel était
son passé non pas du tout des choses
personnelles il avait des idées on
discutait beaucoup des idées de genre
métaphysique ou chose comme ça il aimait
beaucoup les généralités mais je n'ai
jamais jamais pu faire préciser aucun
détail de sa vie passée ou de sa vie qui
expliquerait son acte il était très
méfiant extrêmement oui il vous demandez
de vous goûtiez et sa nourriture c'est
ça pour tous ceux qui de somnifères
et ce qu'il mangeait en plus
essentiellement buvait du café je devais
goûter il respectait un délai d'environ
un quart d'heure avant lui-même de
consommer quoi que ce soit ce qui est
vrai qu'ils vous est demandé à un moment
de que vous le supprimer tout à fait il
disait que si j'avais le choix entre le
fait que lui fasse tous sauter ou le
fait que lui meurt tout seul qu'est-ce
que je préfère ré je pense que vu de
l'extérieur le problème est simple il
m'a dit dans ce cas-là en tant que
médecin de vous devez prendre vos
responsabilités et comment appelle-t-on
aider quelqu'un qui désire mourir et qui
n'a plus de possibilités le tanasie
est-ce que vous avez eu l'impression
d'avoir faire à quelqu'un de lucide de
fou d'intelligent très structuré une
parole très cohérente un vocabulaire
d'un langage courant mais d'un niveau
correct pas très poli voir obséquieux
mais par contre parfois des dérapages de
style bouffer délirante des paroles qui
ne correspondaient plus du tout à la
réalité des délires visuels
l'impression que des gens duraient été
partout vu l'état de stress ça peut être
compréhensible l'impression que des
posters bouger donc il y avait des gens
du raid cachés derrière pour l'attaquer
l'impression de c'est surtout des livres
interprétatif sur les dessins qui
étaient autour de lui est-ce qu'il a
parlé avec les enfants est-ce qu'il leur
a expliqué tout simplement pourquoi il
était là pourquoi il était armé
qu'est-ce qu'il voulait
vendredi matin il est resté environ deux
à trois heures seul avec eux refusant
l'entrée de quiconque à ce moment là
effectivement il était très calme très
agréable avec et il leur a expliqué que
il était lui il voulait pas leur faire
de mal il voulait juste de l'argent et
que c'était la police qui était méchante
parce qu'il voulait pas lui donner de
l'argent mais que lui ne leur voulait
pas de mal il était très gentil avec eux
il avait un excellent contact oui il
était très très agréable
il leur donner les papiers pour dessiner
et s'entretenir avec eux ils les ai joué
et eux comment ont-ils réagi est-ce
qu'ils ont à un moment compris ce qui se
passait réellement ou pas du tout je ne
pense pas il y avait pas d'appréhension
vis-à-vis de lui lui il appelait
monsieur voir le bandit mais le bandit
c'était un nom que lui-même avait
demandé aux enfants de lui donner pas
d'appréhension vrai non plutôt une
interrogation vague en l'occurrence
puisqu'il n'a jamais quitté sa cagoule
exactement au départ il est entré dans
la salle de classe comme disait Laurence
avec l'institutrice avec un casque de
moto qu'il a quitté relativement
rapidement par contre il a gardé un
masque tout le temps du déroulement des
événements est-ce qu'à un moment ou un
autre il vous a dit ce qu'il pensait
faire de cet argent et pourquoi 100
millions pourquoi tant d'argent et pour
faire quoi la somme exacte 200 millions
l'explication est très simple il
estimait qu'il avait une chance sur 100
millions de s'en sortir donc ça vive
allait 100 millions quant à ce qu'il
comptait en faire je n'ai jamais pu
obtenir le moindre renseignement il y a
eu presque un moment avec c'est quand
vous avez compté avec lui les billets ça
devait presque c'est une situation
complètement irréelle oui quand dans la
pièce nous sommes retrouvés Laurent et
moi avec une table comme vous les
imagine dans les maternelles les tables
basses avec les petites chaises et que
la table couverte de billets entre deux
vis étrangères et nous en train il était
je sais plus 3-4h du matin plus
franchement l'état d'esprit à compter et
pas franchement motivé pour faire ça en
train d'essayer de savoir combien il y
avait des millions dans ce qu'il y avait
sur la table c'était le gargouille et il
avait un plan de fuite lui tout à fait
préparé et il vous en avez parlé ou vous
vous saviez comment il voulait partir
est-ce qu'il voulait emmener un enfant
avec lui l'institutrice très réfléchie
qu'il a dû modifier par la suite au
départ il avait donné des polycopies
expliquant il a dû les modifier par la
suite lors des négociations ce plan
c'était simplifié il voit effectivement
dans sa fuite un enfant un parent un
père de préférence parce qu'il avait
peur de l'hystérie d'une mère et une
femme médecin de préférence et il me
disait vous ferez vous ferez donc à
priori moi ensuite quel scénario le
scénario amené une voiture de une
deuxième voiture de rechange dans
l'éventualité d'une panne de la première
voiture
un arrêt lui permettant de se libérer de
cette deuxième voiture si la voiture qui
l'occupait avec les otages était en état
de marche une fuite avec les otages
endormi qu'il libérait à un moment que
lui-même choisissait avec les otages
toujours endormis de manière à ce qu'il
y ait aucune possibilité de savoir
depuis combien de temps il avait fui
donc quelle direction donc tout était
très précis oui c'est aujourd'hui une
certitude c'est se preneur de tâches qui
a perpétré l'attentat il y a exactement
une semaine dans le parking de Neuilly
c'était un attentat signé HB les tracts
qu'il a envoyé cette fois-ci aux
policier était également signé à ce qui
vous a expliqué ce que ça voulait dire
alors lui
très rapidement que le premier attentat
était de lui parce qu'il avait voulu
montrer qu'il n'était pas un bluffeur et
qu'il était capable d'utiliser les
explosifs quant au HB ça a été l'un de
ses grands jeux ainsi que me faire il
avait deux devinettes pour moi l'une qui
était que veut dire HB et l'autre qui
était pourquoi suis-je dangereux
pourquoi suis-je heureux malheureusement
je n'ai pas réussi à trouver la solution
puisque tout ce que j'ai approché que ce
soit sa détermination ses connaissances
pour lui c'était pas la raison
principale quand au HB la devinette au
milieu de la nuit peut-être la fatigue
HB est devenue
c'est à dire la bombe humaine et
effectivement c'était c'était son nom de
code vous avez rencontré bien sûr
souvent parce que vous pouviez sortir de
cette classe les dirigeants les
responsables duraient dit foutent même
faire une confiance absolue à ces hommes
parce que vous vous étiez à l'intérieur
vous saviez qu'il allait intervenir tout
pouvait se terminer en catastrophe parce
que vous êtes bien placé pour savoir que
les bâtons dynamiques c'était pas du des
trucages
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé quand vous
saviez vous poussiez les enfants en
faisant semant de jouer vers dans le
coin de la classe comme vous nous l'avez
expliqué tout là qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans la tête vous dites et si et si
jamais ça rate et si il ouvre un œil
avant et si et puis bon on y passe tous
et si ça rate c'est vrai c'est une
éventualité mais pour avoir côtoyé les
gens du raid pendant 48 heures c'est une
éventualité qui est toujours présente
c'est pour ça qu'on a peur mais qui est
vraiment très faible ils sont
extraordinaires ils ont un côté
professionnel ils sont méticuleux ils
remettent tout en question dans le
moindre détail ils ont un schéma
décisionnel ils sont capables de se
réadapter systématiquement aux
modification de de la situation moi j'ai
pas de mots à leur égard je suis
vraiment restée ébahie devant devant des
gens aussi aussi fort dans leur boulot
Evelyne Lambert 26 ans médecin capitaine
du corps des sapeurs-pompiers de Paris
chevaliers de la Légion d'honneur depuis
ce matin comme elle l'a raconté
elle-même c'est le ravisseur qui s'était
baptisé le bandit auprès des enfants
Eric Schmitt âgé de 42 ans était
originaire de serre un petit village
près de Béziers où vivent encore ses
parents et où se sont rendus bien sûr en
début d'après-midi des policiers de la
baguette criminelle qui cherchent à
reconstituer le passé de cet homme
reportage de nos envies spéciaux
Sandrine meurtre Olivier combe possible
d'atteindre la rue dans laquelle se
trouve la maison familiale de Derrick
Schmitt à Serres près de Béziers dès que
la famille proche du preneur d'otage a
été identifié les forces de police sont
bouclées les rues adjacentes la prise
d'otage a provoqué dans l'opinion
publique qu'un choc émotionnel très fort
et chacun tente de remonter à la source
pour mieux cerner la personnalité de
celui qu'on ne s'est pas encore qualifié
était-il un dangereux malfaiteur ou un
parano idéaliste les policiers sont en
train de passer au crible la maison et
le jardin des parents d'Éric Schmidt il
était chez eux encore début mais
parce que c'est des braves gens et c'est
tout simplement pas de ça mais dans le
film moi je le connais pas je sais pas
quels sont les motifs et donc
une femme comme il faut qu'on les parle
à la meringue
[Musique]
lui et sa sœur semble avoir vécu très
peu de temps au village où leurs parents
sont arrivés après la guerre d'Algérie
sa dernière activité professionnelle
connue a été la gestion d'une entreprise
d'informatique mise par la suite en
liquidation judiciaire il était chômeur
depuis deux ans il n'avait aucun
antécédent judiciaire ou psychiatrique
et le mystère reste entier autour de la
personnalité de celui qui a tenu en
haleine la France entière pendant 48
heures
ville Lambert qui l'a donc côtoyé
pendant de très très longues heures nous
décrivait Eric Schmitt comme un homme
apparemment très structuré a-t-elle dit
mais avec des bouffées délirantes pour
tous ceux qui ont dialogué avec lui Eric
Schmitt apparaissait tout à fait
déterminé et n'avait rien laissé au
hasard sauf peut-être sa propre fatigue
nerveuse Marie Burgaud
qui pendant plus de 46 heures n'a pas
une seule fois
ôter sa cagoule s'appelle donc
Eric Schmitt et son plan il semble bien
la voir échafauder seul face à son
ordinateur ni politique ni truands Éric
Schmitt voulait simplement de l'argent
il voulait aussi qu'on parle de lui
l'attentat dans le parking de Neuilly 5
jours avant la prise d'otage c'était
d'ailleurs déjà lui dans un tract trouvé
sur place il annonçait une prochaine
opération d'envergure et signait HB HB
comme human band la bombe humaine des
initiales qui ne seront pas pour
rassurer les négociateurs
l'analyse des documents remis par
l'individu effectué par un psychiatre
confirmé par ailleurs le caractère de
grande dangerosité
avec une précision d'informaticien
Eric Schmitt alias HB avec tout prévu
pendant toute la prise d'otage il ne
sait d'ailleurs jamais écarté des
grandes lignes de son plan il avait
écrit qu'il préférait mourir plutôt que
d'être pris vivant l'homme sera donc
allé jusqu'au bout de son plan s'était
écrit dans cette salle de classe s'est
arrêté son histoire
créer il y a 8 ans maintenant le raid
est une unité d'élite de 80 policiers
dont l'émission comme le résume le sigle
sont la recherche l'assistance
l'intervention et la dissuasion ces
policiers sont soumis à un intense en
traitement physique bien sûr mais aussi
formé aux techniques psychologiques
essentielles en cas de prise d'otage
reportage Christophe tortorail
une prise d'otage à l'intérieur d'une
banque les tireurs d'élite du raid sont
en place un exercice d'entraînement dans
une usine désaffectée de la région
parisienne les négociations échouées
l'ordre d'abaté de malfaiteurs et
données
le seul résultat qui exigeait
quel que soit le problème posé
on revendique le droit à l'erreur les
gens ne comprennent pas qu'on se trompe
puisqu'on passe notre temps à
s'entraîner pour faire face à des
situations extrêmes le raid initial de
recherche assistance intervention
dissuasion 80 policiers triés sur le
volet cette unité d'élite a été créée en
1985 par Pierre Joxe maître chien plongé
va rap combat rapproché explosif ils
sont tous généraliste mais ont chacun
leur spécialité il s'entraîne afin
d'être prêt à intervenir dans toutes les
situations de crise mais comme on a pu
le voir à l'école maternelle ils
interviennent uniquement lorsqu'il n'y a
plus aucune autre solution de la
négociation fait partie intégrante pour
nous de l'intervention si nous pouvons
résoudre une situation en utilisant que
la négociation nous pensons avoir réussi
notre mission et dès que la mission est
confiée au raid le raid a l'entière
responsabilité de la totalité de la
mission c'est-à-dire qu'il va choisir le
les moyens employés et le moment du
déclenchement de l'intervention le raid
a participé à l'arrestation des
terroristes d'action direct en 1987 et à
ceux de leter à l'année dernière mais
outre ses missions tout terroristes ils
assurent également la protection
rapprochée des chefs d'État ou la
sécurité de site comme ceux des Jeux
Olympiques d'Albertville en 1992 une
vingtaine de fois par an ils sont
appelés pour des forcenets des missions
qu'il considèrent comme les plus
difficiles
si la situation vous sentez
particulièrement mal à l'aise
oui plus particulièrement je crois les
l'histoire de forcené de dingue parce
que bon ce sont quand même pas sont plus
des malades qu'autre chose donc on n'a
pas disons que du terrorisme ou des
voyous on sait à qui on a affaire et ils
ont choisi
un forcené c'est souvent un type qui a
déconnecté c'est problématique pour nos
intervenir mais ce matin l'intervention
était devenue inévitable elle s'est fort
heureusement parfaitement déroulée
avec nous invitée de ce journal un
médecin qui a été très étroitement
associé à ce drame le docteur Gilles
nakab psychiatre à l'Hôtel-Dieu et qui a
aidé les familles à gérer leur anxiété
mais aussi assister les négociateurs et
les policiers en analysant la prose et
les déclarations du ravisseur et en les
conseillant éventuellement sur la
conduite à tenir merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce soir je suppose que vous
êtes très très fatigué donc nous a
l'impression d'autant plus le fait que
soyez venus nous voir comment vous avez
travaillé avec ces policiers du Raid
face à ce que ce policier qualifié de
dingue entre guillemets premièrement
j'ai travaillé plus particulièrement
avec un des membres du raid celui qui
était plutôt chargé de la de la relation
avec l'extérieur et donc en particulier
les familles
nous étions donc confrontés à chaque
fois qu'il y avait une négociation
à pouvoir être tenté d'analyser ce qu'on
pouvait entendre puisque les enfants
faisaient il faut préciser que la salle
était sonorisée la salle était sonorisée
avec beaucoup d'enfants qui jouaient
rigolaient chanter ce qui gênait
beaucoup donc les côtes
bon essayer d'approcher au plus près la
psychologie peut-être du moi je
l'appelle le malade bien sûr en tant que
médecin
comment faites vous vous lui faites
passer par l'intermédiaire de de cette
femme médecin des pompiers ou par
l'institutrice des questions précises à
poser pour pouvoir analyser ses réponses
si vous voulez le raid organise
absolument tout
si on avait pu me demander en passion on
était venu à me demander d'intervenir
bien entendu j'y sera allé mais je crois
que ça me faisait pas partie d'un des
scénarios possibles
des questions des je crois que si une
intervention psychiatrique est envisagée
j'en ai discuté avec ce que
je suis assez fatigué avec le membre du
raid avec qui je travaillais c'était
proposé de poser une ou deux questions
pour voir peut-être s'il y avait pas une
activité délirante de ce qui est exprimé
en dessous mais je crois qu'il fallait
avoir les questions
qui pouvait suivre on pourrait
évidemment c'est intéressant pour le
psychiatre et même pour le raid de des
laborer d'essayer de financer les
processus psychopathologiques du malade
mais je crois pas que ça correspond
vraiment à la situation quel degré selon
vous de dangerosité comme on dit
avait-il nous d'emblée d'emblée puisque
j'avais relayé de collègues qui étaient
là dès le début de l'après-midi dans la
journée de jeudi on l'avait qualifié de
dangerosité extrême ne serait-ce qu'à la
lecture de vous savez des 8 feuilles
qu'il avait qu'il avait remis au story
Lambert parlé d'un homme vous l'avez
entendu d'un homme très structuré à tel
dit mais avec des bouffées délirantes
est-ce que vous partagez ce diagnostic
entre guillemets encore une fois parce
qu'elle n'est pas psychiatre oui mais je
crois que bon un bon médecin comme elle
a du sens clinique alors on observe des
signes peut-être que les diagnostics
sont pour après effectivement un homme
froid déterminé calme j'ai beaucoup
écouté ses paroles il y avait toujours à
ton monocorde
des phrases rythmées
on ne sentait jamais lâcher la pression
au moins disons pendant les jusqu'au aux
deux tiers de la première nuit dernière
question vous disiez que quand il
parlait avec les enfants il est très
gentil vous disiez c'était pas du tout
le même homme ah voilà ça c'est plus le
même homme si on sait cet appartient de
dire après-midi
beaucoup d'empathie de chaleur avec ses
enfants ce qui nous avait quand même et
moi-même en particulier pas mal
interroger pourquoi cet homme si froid
si distant
s'intéressait comme ça aux enfants avec
autant de gentillesse les faisant
dessiner faisant attention qu'il fasse
pipi dans leur culotte et tout de même
non je crois qu'il n'a jamais été
menaçant à l'égard des enfants je crois
que là tous les témoignages que ce soit
les parents qui sont rentrés donc dans
la salle de classe n'est jamais menacé
évidemment il y avait le risque qu'il
appuie sur le déclencheur de de la bombe
des explosifs mais en aucun cas une
amené un enfant d'ailleurs il était vécu
par les enfants comme quelqu'un de
gentil les méchants c'était les hommes
en noirs moi j'avais fait une petite
association comme ça qui a été beaucoup
discuté avec les certains membres du
raid c'était venait un peu à moi les
petits-enfants ce qui peut-être changer
notre vision des choses mais bon devant
le la gravité de la situation je ne sais
pas si c'était le primordial merci
beaucoup docteur pour ce témoignage nous
allons vous laisser les vous reposer
merci trois heures après le dénouement
donc Charles Pasqua a tenu une
conférence de presse au ministère
l'occasion pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur d'expliquer la stratégie
policière à savoir
identifier le risque privilégier le
dialogue on l'a vu mais aussi préparer
une intervention en force
aussitôt l'alerte donnée
j'ai défini le cadre de l'intervention
de la police ne rien faire qui puisse
mettre en péril la sécurité des enfants
et de l'institutrice
n'intervenir par la force que si cela
s'avérait compatible avec la sécurité
des enfants ou en cas de menace
immédiate ou de début de violence à leur
égard
n'accepter à aucun cas que l'individu
amène avec lui des enfants dans sa fuite
je voudrais naturellement
signaler tout particulièrement et
adressé les remerciements du
gouvernement et aussi les félicitations
du gouvernement à l'institutrice madame
Laurence Dreyfus qui dans cette affaire
a fait preuve à la fois d'un courage
exceptionnel et de qualité
professionnelle
tout à fait remarquable il convient
également aussi et je crois que le maire
de Neuilly qui
intervenu à de nombreuses reprises dans
cette affaire n'a pas manqué de le faire
auprès de moi de signaler le calme et le
courage des parents des enfants
notamment des six qui étaient détenus à
nouveau commentaire
sans le calme de ses parents et la
confiance qui nous ont manifesté celles
qu'ils ont manifesté au maire de nuit
celles qu'ils ont manifesté aux
responsables des forces de sécurité
notre tâche aurait été rendu extrament
difficile pour ne pas dire impossible je
voudrais également
signaler le comportement exceptionnel de
Madame Évelyne Lambert médecin capitaine
de la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de
Paris ces deux femmes ont joué un rôle
décisif dans cette affaire elle nous ont
permis d'intervenir le mouvement venu
dans de bonnes conditions et aussi sans
que les enfants non seulement ne
subissent pas de violence mais je
l'espère qu'il ne reste dans leur esprit
aucune trace de cette affaire
extrêmement
délicate sur le Pasqua vient de faire
allusion au bon comportement des parents
concernés Anne guéri a rencontré
précisément les parents du petit Quentin
trois ans il avait été libéré jeudi vers
19h alors qu'il commençait à manifester
un patient et inquiétude ce qui semble
contredire l'idée que tous les petits
otages ont attendu dans le calme ou la
sérénité l'issue de ce drame
il a été libéré parce que prenant compte
que la situation dans la classe était
anormale il avait refusé de prendre tout
aliment et toute boisson qui avait été
amenée dans la classe donc il était en
fin de journée très affaiblie mais on
sait que certains ont eu des trous
intestinaux
d'autres ont eu d'autres troubles qui
ont fait que je crois que les plus
résistants ont été libérés en dernier
alors que ceux qui présentaient des
troubles ont été libéré probablement
avant les autres ce qui nous a dit quand
même
plus tard dans la soirée c'est qu'il y
avait un monsieur qui était en la classe
que ce monsieur était méchant avec la
maîtresse parce qu'il voulait de
l'argent
que il était armé d'un pistolet c'était
probablement pour chasser les loups
et puis plus tard il nous a dit quand
même que il a demandé pourquoi personne
n'était venu battre le monsieur
donc ce qui montre que quand même les
enfants ont pris conscience à un moment
donné que une situation anormale
s'installer et que il s'étonnait que
peut-être leurs parents ou d'autres
adultes
ne viennent pas les libérer enfin ne
viennent pas leur secours rien ne laisse
penser que il y aura des séquelles
lorsque ils n'ont pas eu de violence
dirigées contre eux et parce que cette
maîtresse a su être un petit peu le
tampon ou le paravent
à la situation de traumatisme et je
crois qu'on va essayer de se couper de
tout ça et de et de reprendre une vie
normale et et retrouver notre fontanéité
nous n'avons pas encore retrouvé le dire
cette prise d'otage dans une maternelle
là évidemment aucun précédent au moins
en France et jamais médecin psychiatre
et psychologue n'auront été autant mises
à contribution que ce soit comme on l'a
vu il y a un instant pour dresser le
profil psychologique du ravisseur ou
pour apprécier l'impact de ce drame sur
les enfants et surtout les adultes
concernés avec nous Paul Michel Schmidt
qui est pédopsychiatre bonsoir
rapidement comment éviter des séquelles
psychologiques graves pour les enfants
mais aussi pour les parents de cette
épreuve ce qui est formidable c'est que
les enfants et les familles sortent
vainqueurs d'une part et deuxièmement il
faut faire confiance aux enfants leur
petite âge leur permet d'aménager de
reproduire comme on l'a déjà dit
d'oublier aussi donc je crois qu'il faut
que les gens se regroupent il faut
qu'ils sachent se relâcher mais aussi il
faut que les parents s'entraident des
uns les autres car peut-être eux avec
leur sensibilité le fait d'avoir été
éloigné pendant 48 heures ils vont ils
vont peut-être dans un dans un deuxième
temps elle une vraie éventuellement donc
moi je crois grande confiance aux
enfants être authentique et spontané
mais se soutenir en tant que parents
dans les jours qui suivent et surtout
pas intérioriser tout à l'heure le père
de cet enfant disait on va se couper
tout ça c'est peut-être pas forcément
absolument se laisser aller à dire mais
on a le temps de dire les choses mais
surtout restez ouvert prendre son temps
mais restez ouvert et dire les choses
est-ce qu'il y a des procédures prévues
pour ce genre de cas où est-ce que ses
parents ses enfants vont être plus ou
moins suivis par leur médecin ou est-ce
que vous savez que que
les maltraitances au sens général du
terme sont un problème très général
actuellement nous avons par exemple à
l'hôpital Trousseau des cellules de
l'enfance en difficulté et maltraités
dans lesquelles nous nous prenons en
charge des parents dans des
circonstances très diverses donc je
crois que théoriquement les médecins les
pédiatres et les psychiatres sont tout à
fait à même d'aider ou de conseiller à
distance ces familles merci beaucoup
docteur suite pour ces précisions
informées à la toute première minute
bien sûr de la libération des six
fillettes ce matin François Mitterrand a
demandé au ministre de l'Intérieur de
transmettre ses félicitations je cite à
tous les personnels qui ont contribué au
sauvetage de ces enfants ils doivent
Balladur s'était rendu sur place on l'a
vu à Neuilly quelques minutes après le
dénouement peu après en visite à Mâcon
le Premier ministre a fait part de sa
joie et de son soulagement
c'est une réaction de soulagement et de
et vraiment de joie la France a vécu
pendant deux jours dans un drame
et je dois dire que ce que j'ai trouvé
admirable dans ces circonstances c'est
de comportement de tous ceux qui se sont
attachés à soutenir les parents les
enfants il s'agisse des membres du corps
enseignant qu'il s'agisse des membres du
corps médical ou des membres des forces
de l'ordre leur comportement a été
admirable et je suis sûr d'exprimer le
sentiment de tous les Français en leur
disant notre reconnaissance pour ceux
qui ont fait
[Musique]